imbula bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france
alors que penser de la communication des
manuels macron ces derniers jours alors
il ya eu le fait qu'il n'ait pas fêter
les fêtes de noël il est aussi le colis
dont le rappel il a été lui-même
contaminés oui une communication
brouillonne assez particulière puisque
emmanuel macron a été un de ses chefs
d'état qui a attrapé le coc vide il ya
eu avant lui
donald trump jr ball sonar ou boris
johnson avec des communications très
différentes un trump revient en
hélicoptère à la maison blanche après
avoir vaincu le virus bolton arrosé de
la moto ans allemand les brésiliens et
boris johnson lui remercie lan et
chaises de manière assez humbles et
modèles macro lui à un pardon fait un
selphy à la lanterne expliquant qu'il
allait bien qu'il fallait faire
attention avec tout le monde puis il a
disparu passant les fêtes à brégançon
l'anniversaire sol on ne sait pas trop
et est pourtant dans le même temps il
avait donné beaucoup d'interviews à la
presse notamment une grande interview il
parlait de refaire un débat sur
l'identité nationale et voilà kemmel
macron décide de ne pas souhaiter noël
aux français alors c'est un débat qui a
lieu à peu près tous les ans ou tous les
cas kenna parfois les présidents
souhaitent noël aux français parfois non
c'est devenu quasiment une habitude
d'essayer de ne pas le faire on se
demande bien pourquoi puisque même pour
les français de confession musulmane ça
ne pose pas vraiment de problème de dire
jouer noël puisque les présidents
n'hésite pas à saluer d'autres fêtes
religieuses qui ont lieu en france mais
on ne peut pas gagner quand on est
président d'une république laïque comme
la france avec ce débat sur la laïcité
qui fait rage qui n'arrête pas 1905
et pourtant réouvert année après année
donc construite noël ou qu'on ne
souhaite pas noël quand on est président
on ne peut contenter personne mais avec
emmanuel macron ça devient problématique
parce que il arrive maintenant avec son
en même temps à ne contente est vraiment
plus personne et on n'arrive pas à
comprendre quelle est sa communication
alexis poulain le chef de l'état hier
s'est réjoui du lancement de cette
campagne de vaccination plutôt
symbolique 1 seulement une vingtaine de
personnes devant les devant les caméras
il dit qu on est armé à présent qu'en
pensez vous
oui alors il dit que le vaccin est une
nouvelle arme un contre ce virus qu'il
va falloir rester ensemble et que la
vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire il
l'aura
parce que là on peut parler encore de
ratés de communication présidentielle ou
de communication de l'exécutif on parle
de campagne de vaccination qui commence
il s'agit surtout d'une campagne de
communication sur la campagne de
vaccination parce qu'on a très peu de
doses
on a vu ses résidents d pad à sevran
notamment maurice est la première à se
faire vacciner devant les caméras d'une
chaîne française qui ne comprenaient pas
ce qu'elle faisait là dedans a mais il
faut se faire vacciner
donc déjà un petit bug de communication
assez grave en fait puisqu'on parle de
comptes effectivement là les paléo
compte ce qui se passait c'était quand
même assez déconcertante
c'était assez déconcertant puisqu'il la
pause sur une chaise c'est même gênant
c'est cette séquence et puis on le
descend une manche elle dira mais c'est
pour un vaccin
donc c'est à se demander ce qu'on a dit
à 7 à cette femme avant qu'elle arrive
devant les caméras il ya quelque chose
d'un peu obscène de mettre en scène
comme ça quelqu'un qui a droit aussi au
secret médical après tout pourquoi
filmer les premiers vaccinés on peut se
demander les français d'ailleurs je
parlais de deux ratés de communication
sont de moins en moins convaincu 1 de se
faire vacciner
puisqu'on est passé à 40 % seulement de
français interrogés par santé publique
france qui disent vouloir certainement
ou probablement se faire vacciner ses 13
points de moins qu'en novembre
et surtout l'adhésion est en baisse chez
les plus de 65 ans qui sont pourtant les
cibles prioritaires du vaccin ils sont
passés de 2 72% il ya deux mois à
seulement 61 % à vouloir tester ce
nouveau vaccin dont on ne sait pas
encore assez de choses finalement sur le
retour sur cette technologie est reine
qui pose question et surtout sur son
efficacité
donc que va-t-il se passer c'était jean
castex qui avait promis de la
transparence de la vigilance et le de la
détermination dans cette campagne de
vaccination la transparence évidemment
on va attendre de voir parce qu'on n'a
toujours pas le nombre de doses total
l'idée c'est d'avoir quand même les 700
mille patients prioritaire d pad qui
vont être vaccinés d'ici février et puis
ensuite 15 millions de français avant
l'été reste à savoir si cette campagne
va fonctionner si les français vont y
adhérer
aujourd'hui on voit que ni les ministres
ni l'exécutif ne montre vraiment
l'exemple
contrairement à d'autres pays où vous
avez joe biden qui se fait vacciner vous
avez
d'autres d'autres dirigeants qui ont une
autre approche là la campagne commence
un peu sur des oeufs
sachant que les français au pays de
pasteur et pays de descartes attente de
voir cette épreuve de ce nouveau vaccin
avant toute chose alors alexis un vague
se présentait donc comme une nouvelle
arme en tout cas ça va pas empêcher a
priori un nouveau confinement en tout
cas la question est sur la table
et oui la question est sur la table à
croire que l'on va vivre maintenant
confiné à advitam eternam c'est un peu
triste c'est assez ennuyeux c'est même
catastrophique surtout pour les
commerces qui sont fermés depuis des
mois pour des secteurs entiers qui ne
voient pas de réouverture à l'horizon et
puis les dégâts psychologiques de ces
confinement qui sont nombreux
et puis la précarité aussi pour de
nombreux étudiants qui n'arrivent pas à
s'en sortir donc on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça à un moment il va
falloir aussi comprendre que si le
confinement est la dernière des
solutions
il y en a peut-être d'autres aussi il ya
d'autres pays qui ont peut-être réussi à
s'organiser autrement
mais c'est vrai que ça commence à être
un peu gros de de lâcher la bride et
puis de re confiné et de recommencer
donc ce serait du stop and go comme
comme on dit jusqu'à l'été puisque le
virus serait censé disparaître de
manière miraculeuse selon certains
prophètes du virus à partir de l'été que
ce soit jacques attali ou karen lacombe
disent que ce sera fini en septembre
donc pourquoi avoir autant de
confinement d'ici là c'est la question
qui se pose alors que l'on pourrait
avoir des peut-être confinement ciblées
sur les personnes fragiles justement qui
attendent les vaccins ou autres et
laisser vivre les autres
normalement sachant que le vaccin est là
donc normalement on devrait pouvoir d
confiné d'ailleurs la grande bretagne a
un objectif très clair de vaccination et
de déconfinement à partir de fin février
je crois que le gouvernement français
lui souhaite jouer l'opacité ne pas
annoncer les confinements ou plutôt les
annoncé en dernière minute on peut
appeler ça de l'amateurisme on peut
appeler ça de l'improvisation ou bien
une gestion fragile de cette crise
sanitaire
alexis poulain 40% des français vaccinés
d'ici à l'été vous y croyez à cet
objectif du gouvernement
il faut rétablir la confiance vous
l'avez dit les français sont assez
réticents à se faire vacciner
pour établir la confiance il faudrait
par exemple que jean castex fassent
vacciner pour montrer l'exemple et bien
ce serait un bon début
qu'un ministre ou un premier ministre
devant les caméras se fassent vacciner
plutôt que cette pauvre morissette qui
ne savaient pas ce qu'elle faisait
devant les caméras qu'il commence da par
eux la confiance elle commence par là je
crois que s'ils veulent mettre en scène
des gens qui se font vacciner alors
qu'ils soient les premiers à se faire
vacciner même s'ils ne sont pas comme
ils le disent de la population cible ils
ont un rôle quand même de deux leaders
de modèles d'une certaine façon même si
on peut se poser la question est donc
l'acceptation se fera de cette façon là
et puis l'autre chose aussi c'est les
premiers vaccinés seront aussi ceux qui
vont rassurer en disant qu'il ne s'est
rien passé que finalement oui ils ont
échappé au virus que ça marche
et donc ils vont convaincre les autres
mais pour ça il faut attendre les 21
jours la deuxième inoculation du vaccin
et puis mes quelques semaines les
quelques mois pour être sûrs que ceux
qui ont été vaccinés n'ont pas attrapé
le virus ou une version atténuée et ne
sont pas contagieuses ça ça reste à voir
pour rassurer le reste de la population
40 % à l'été c'est peut-être possible
reste à savoir si on aura le nombre de
vaccins nécessaires combien toute cette
campagne va coûter et quelle est
l'efficacité encore une fois je le redis
pour limiter la contagion puisque l'idée
quand même c'est d'arriver à sortir de
ces confinement la pétition de retrouver
une vie normale
partant de virus or rien rien n'est sûr
aujourd'hui
attendons de voir nos voisins européens
notamment la grande bretagne qui a une
campagne plus massive
si le l'impact de cette vaccination est
réel il nous reste un petit peu de temps
alexis poulain on voit les maires monte
au créneau et ils voudraient pouvoir
décider d'un confinement locale ce
serait une des solutions davantage de
consultations en tout cas oui de toute
façon depuis le début c'est l'idée c'est
de se dire le virus ne se propage pas de
la même façon puisqu'on parlait de
clusters rappelez-vous au début un
ferment de bassins identifié de
contamination du virus
là on a tout oublié tout se fait au
national peu importe les réalités
locales donc après tout oui pourquoi pas
navoy avoir des réalités plus fine de
gestion par les territoires c'est les
maires qui savent eux le
en lien avec les préfets également
puisque l'état veut avoir un oeil
partout c'est possible mais une gestion
plus fine de cette crise me semble
urgente nécessaire notamment pour les
catégories que je citais précédemment
les commerçants les restaurateurs le
monde de la culture les étudiants le
monde universitaire qui souhaitent
reprendre une vie normale
sachant que eux ne sont pas des
populations à risque comme les autres
tout ça est assez différent donc je
crois qu'il est temps de revenir à une
gestion beaucoup plus fine de cette
crise sanitaire plutôt que c'est
confinement nationaux décrété mois après
mois sans savoir vraiment quel est leur
efficacité réelle puisque on ne parle
que de courbes de chiffres de projection
rappelez-vous mails macron parler de
400000 amor potentiel de ce virus
on en est très très loin et on se
félicite en faisant baisser parce qu on
a confiné
bon alors tout ça c'est gérer la santé
et les français avec des algorithmes
s'est pas vraiment géré de manière
sanitaires et concrète cette crise qui
touche évidemment tous les pays
européens n'y a pas de recette miracle
malheureusement mais là ça devient
critique et je pense pas qu'on puisse
vivre 2021 comme on a dit vécu 2020 et
d'ailleurs pour de nombreux commerçants
c'est déjà très difficile et ils
paieront boutique en 2021 et cette
catastrophe là je ne vois pas le
gouvernement l'a préparée merci beaucoup
alexis poulin et je le rappelle on vous
retrouve tous les lundis matin dans
l'édito de la matinale